[Music]
okay i just sent you something hilarious
i've been following this twitter called
mug shotties
and
it's like a play on mug shots and we
talked about this
did we talk about mug shotties
it's so
funny and the tagline is uh the tagline
is uh hope bay gets bail
uh and it's mug shouty's and it's all
like good-looking girls who have a mug
shot it's hilarious it's so funny
yeah we've talked about that because
there was the guy who
his mug shot went viral because he's got
like he's just like really stunningly
good looking and he became like a model
after afterwards or whatever
yeah i remember that guy people still
talk about him can i tell you crazy
story yes uh
so
have you ever seen i think this is
probably outside of your
your like kind of orbit of what you pay
attention to but have you seen these
gambling live streams where drake will
go on twitch and he'll gamble like 20
million dollars live on stream
no really yeah like a like real 20
million dollars a real 20 million like
he lost like i think 17 million dollars
on roulette one night last like two
weeks ago or something like that it
seemed really that rich that i mean like
if you're
200 million dollar rich that's ten
percent of your net worth in a night no
okay that's a substantial amount good
question i had the same question which
led me to some pretty interesting
findings okay so um
so i saw drake doing this and i've seen
other
popular streamers like xqc and these
guys they do these gambling streams from
time to time people love to see it
because they're playing kind of like
high stakes online uh you know gambling
and they're reacting to the highs and
lows or whatever uh ben have you seen
this i think it's probably also outside
of your you know mormon orbit you don't
watch these kinds of sins
yeah
exactly so
this is all on twitch it's happening on
tw it was happening on twitch maybe some
people do it on youtube as well but it
got me curious i was like there's no way
this guy's gambling 25 million dollars
20 million dollars of his own money
on these things and i was like these
streams get so popular i'm like this is
actually great marketing for the website
that it's on so he's he's gambling on
something called stake.com
s-t-a-k-e and um
so i was like i bet this is house money
that they're giving him in order to just
promote the site and sure enough that's
what it is so get this but is he is he
losing it again when you play blackjack
you lose against the dealer right house
yeah so they're just okay like if i gave
you 20 million dollars to come play my
rigged game
i gave you 20 million you lose it right
back to me i get not i don't know you
know i'm back whole um they don't even
lose the vig because they're the house
so they would take that you know four
percent edge or whatever that they would
have they keep that as well
um and if you win maybe they have some
deal where like hey if you win you keep
the winnings uh i would assume they have
some deal like that with him but
it's electronic right like it's like the
cards are digital it's not like a camera
so then
they could just be like oh shoot drake
has 20 we have to make ourselves have
21. yeah well that's yeah that's a
little bit that's illegal for sure but
they wouldn't need to do that i guess
that's kind of my point is that they'll
already have a house edge
and uh over time like they will win
and so and even if they don't like this
is as a marketing campaign like uh this
is like kind of genius and so what
they're doing is
stake.com is this website and it is the
largest
cryptocurrency based online gambling
site in the world
and nobody knew who was behind it
until recently some guy in australia
bought like a 36 million dollar home
and they were like who who is this
you're in your 20s how did you buy a 36
million home all cash like what was he
he was he was in his 20s
so these guys they're in their mid-20s i
think one guy's 25 or 26 the other guy's
28.
and um and so there's this guy ed you
can just search ed craven uh ed craven
steak and you'll see
the secret origins the secret australian
origins of the world's biggest crypto
casino
and so get this so basically they have
online
there's these guys in um in australia
and they've got this office and it's
just like and the the office is under
this name called easy go gaming it's
like we build online uh games
and the office is super nice and people
would see it on social media they would
see like wow these guys got like a chef
and they got all these perks and they
got like they're always going on these
trips and like what's going on with man
easy go gaming you guys must be an
awesome gaming company so
it must just be like a couple people and
they're just hanging out at someone's
house
and so well no no so this is a legit
company but basically easy go gaming is
the licensed gaming provider like they
provide the games
to the casino company steak which is
based in some place called curacao or
something like that which is like some
dutch caribbean island uh where the
actual casino is based and these guys
own both so they were kind of known as
only the owners of easy go but they
actually own steak
and so it all got kind of like
revealed when the guy bought this home
for whatever you can see even there's
like a daily mail article he buys i'm
reading it right now
dot org yeah 38 and a half million
dollar mansion he buys and um they're
like who is this kid he's 26 years old
or whatever
and that's kind of how people figured
out like oh he owns steak.com now i i
believe these are kind of like my
predictions my guesses
so steak.com i think is pretty clearly
clearing like billions of dollars in
revenue i think both of these guys are
now
self-made billionaires possibly even 10
billion plus is what they've made off of
steak.com because this thing is a
absolute
cash cow and you can kind of back into
this by looking at like um
they do these like sunday raffle
whatever lottery type thing and it's
like you pay it's like oh wow you know
250 000 people bought this like ten
dollar ticket it's like oh wow they just
you know that was just like a two two
and a half million dollar sunday for
them and then they pay out this much and
they keep 26 million or 50 million like
that's just a week for them and so um
and so you can kind of see
you could kind of back into i did some
some calculations on it but but i'm
pretty sure that these guys are both
self-made billionaires if not 10 billion
at this point uh in equity value of
stake.com
and it's just kind of crazy to me like
that this exists that these guys are so
young able to do this and um
and people who are just willing to like
live on the edge it's like yeah i'm
gonna go set up a company at the dutch
caribbean island of curacao which gives
out like online gambling licenses like
you know my neighborhood gives up candy
on halloween and these guys have amassed
this absolute fortune kind of
anonymously building this isn't this
just like isn't this kind of crazy to
you
yeah this is i'm researching and i know
how i recognize this they're a sponsor
of the ufc
yes and so they're big ufc sponsors they
also sponsor watford the like uh the
english soccer team so they like pay 10
million a year as their like lead uh
lead sponsor for that too
so i'm doing research just as as you're
talking um
on linkedin there's
i i don't
well here one guy says he's the ceo but
that seemed i don't know if that's legit
uh this is this is crazy this is one of
those amazing companies this just like
vpn and a few other things that's
completely under the radar and it's
totally crushing and i've said this to
you before i actually think that
people's personal homes
the price of it it you know like a rich
person can live in a low priced home but
if you purchase a high priced home the
likelihood that you're rich is like it's
indicative of what you have because it's
hard it's not impossible but it's hard
to give a bank to give you a loan if you
don't have a significant amount of
income not just assets but income so if
he bought a 30 and if he bought a 37
million dollar home in cash is that
really what it said so then
yeah i don't know if it was all cash uh
but it was like three times more the
house sold in 2018 for three times less
and then the guy renovated it and he
this guy bought it for for whatever
almost 42. to buy a 40 million home i
would think you'd want to be worth like
at least 250 million dollars in at least
some type of liquid situation as well
not just privately held company
so here's my notes on this thing so i'm
just going to read you my raw notes from
last night it says
a small company in australia in
melbourne called easy go
looks like your typical successful
startup you got pingtang tables you got
a chef you got perks you're going on on
on boat trips with the with the team but
they're hiding a massive secret they're
also the founders of steak which i
believe might be the world's largest
casino ever it's crypto only which is a
massive growth level does that mean that
it that it's legal
um
you mean illegal i don't know the
legality of it that's like probably a
pretty complicated thing like like full
tilt went away in america i used to play
tilt yeah
you can't go if you're on state.com in
the us you can't go to it it's like no
this is not available to us citizens um
but it but internationally it is and
they they based out of curacao which
gives out the online gamble so i think
they are fully licensed but they use uh
crypto which i think lets them do things
like no um
as they say kyc aml like know your
customer so basically i think you could
just transfer in bitcoin or whatever and
you could just gamble it on the site uh
you just put an email and you start
gambling and uh so they got like all
these games or whatever
um
i think that they're paying drake like
20 million dollars a month to be the
like sponsor of this thing no way
that
because he's gambling at those stakes
and i'm pretty sure that's all house
money i don't think drake is promoting
this company for by by putting in 20
million dollars of his own money and
losing it every month well they're not
they're not giving him 20 million
dollars they're saying you can win up to
20 or you could know they're giving them
house money they're giving them a chip
or a credit line that basically says
here's 20 million to go play on the site
you probably can't just cash that out
you have to gamble it here um but but
i'm pretty sure that's how it's working
that would be crazy i mean i i like okay
so the private some of the private
equity guys like um steve schwartzman
and uh a few other folks who founded
carlisle and black rock and blackstone
and all that
there was there's some years where
they'll get paid like 800 million
dollars or 500 million dollars because
of performance but um
20 million a month is 240 million
dollars a year that would they're
probably i can't imagine there's more
than 100 people in the whole world that
earn that much income i mean of course
there's a lot of people who earn like
paper gains but who earn that much
income in a given year that would be
absolutely astounding so get this so
they so the guy buys this house for 40
million they also own multiple
penthouses like the top floor of the
eureka tower in melbourne which was the
largest skyscraper but here's what's
even more interesting when they were 18
um when one of them was 18 the other
guy's 20. they started something called
primedice.com it's still up if you go to
primedice.com it's basically
a crypto gambling site or you just bet
is it gonna be uh like what what's gonna
happen it's like a heads or tails it's
like a roll of the dice
and uh you could just wager on it
and like
you know here you go and you can just
see people just betting constantly on
what the dice is gonna roll out to right
and like what they're gonna what they're
gonna win for it so
they created this when they were
back in i don't know uh 2013 it says i
think on the site says largest crypto
gambling site since 2013. uh so they're
pretty early on that
um
this site is
wild do you see all the live users
betting money yeah it's crazy
and uh it's just look at this one guy
shane recovers just betting over and
over again
this company this is this is such an
amazing five fine this company alone
this prime dice thing is awesome so then
let me tell you some of the the other
things that that come into it so uh so
basically um i think one of the
youtubers that they pay or or maybe a
twist shimmery this guy aiden ross i
think is getting paid a few million
bucks per month to to do it that that i
think there's pretty good authority on
um three million dollars a month yeah uh
i know i think two two million a month
um okay now let me go into more okay so
all of that was like you know this is
all like not confirmed but like these
are now like some rumors
so uh or i guess this part's not a rumor
like if you go to their website you
could see that there's a company called
medium rare nv which is incorporated in
curacao that's the company that holds
the gaming license if you google map the
address
it's just like a shitty warehouse
building
that you'll find of like where this
company is based
so i don't know what's going on there
it's like you know when you incorporate
in delaware and they give you like a p.o
box as your address
um
so okay and then a couple of other you
know random rumors are like
uh they had they had they added um
dogecoin to their site as like a way to
deposit back in the day and like when
all the elon stuff was happening i think
they dumped like hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of doge they like sold it
all but the elon pump was happening to
dogecoin
um
and uh yeah it's crazy so so anyways
this is just like a crazy thing well
what like okay let's say you even had
the idea for this i googled i googled
i'm googling these guys as you're
talking there's very very very little
information on these folks right there's
so there's almost nothing i do you think
could i change my browser to australia
and maybe get better results because i'm
googling their names now and there is
like there's one picture on them on the
whole on everything yeah i like found
their instagrams both their instagrams
are private but like uh yeah like i know
somebody who who falls over whatever so
i like stalked their instagram too just
to see like what's going on and it's are
they jacked are they jacked bros now or
are they still nerds they're uh they're
i wouldn't say they're jacked but
they're fit uh and they're bros for sure
like they're breaking the stereotype you
know like here's the like i'm just going
to describe to you uh i'll send this
photo we can put this in the other
ferrari pictures okay so one okay
picture number one uh
you would have guessed ferrari but
here's a close second
picture of a range rover with a giant
bow and somebody hugging them because
they just gave them a range rover uh
okay that's a classic you gotta love
that one another classic you know the
like influencer balloons you get when
you cross like a million followers or
whatever the yellow giant inflatable
balloon of a number they have that uh
and it's like some guy uh you know
hugging him doing that another one like
courtside at the lakers game courtside
at the french open like i could seen the
doll's calf like you know right behind
this guy's head in this picture so
they're definitely living it up uh and
as they should this is what this is
exactly what i want my
online casino dealer guys life to be
this is who i wanted to be and this is
how i want them to live and i'm glad
that they are doing exactly what they're
doing and one of them's only 26 is what
you're saying yeah and this article
might be a little out of date but uh
yeah that is they definitely they
definitely hit this scale when they were
in their 20s like the youngest rich the
richest young person in the world like
uh
richer than what's his name the sam
bankman freed guy yeah and younger or on
par with it and and younger that is
outstanding that is crazy what a good
find
speaking of young billionaires uh i
think the world's youngest
self-billionaire now is
this guy alexander wang do you know this
guy i
i don't really know him i think i was in
a group chat with him um is that from
that company uh a startup yeah yeah yeah
so what they do is pretty cool um they
basically saw the kind of like machine
learning
um
trend you know like
this is going to keep growing and they
were like well you know what one thing
that's really hard is like when you're
doing machine learning
you need like the data to be labeled
right so if you're trying to teach a
computer how to recognize a a you know a
kitten or something like that it's like
you first have to train it in some ways
or be able to like um teach it when it's
wrong and correct it
and um
so that labeling process is quite like
time-consuming and so what they did was
they created like a i think a giant
workforce force of overseas people that
will
label your images for you and so like if
you're a self-driving car company if
you're uh waymo or or tesla whatever you
get like tons and tons of footage and
then now those need to be labeled as
like yep that was a dog crossing the
street yep that's a stop sign even
though it's partially obstructed and so
how does that happen that's like a human
intervention humans go and do that and
so scale started off as like a
it was labeling as a service i i'm sure
they do a lot more stuff now but it's
pretty crazy that's like a 10 billion
dollar company now and this guy i think
he started it when he was 19 or
something what
um is he cool
yeah he was cool uh i i didn't know him
for long because as soon as there it's
pretty funny it's like i'm in this group
chat that's like four
founders um yeah four for a bunch of
founders it's like oh it's kind of like
the underground founders hang out like
we chill here and everybody's trying to
do big things but then when one guy
actually started doing big things he's
like i'm busy i need to leave this now
and so it's like the ultimate signal
it's like oh and it really takes off
you don't spat out
him
you just sort of like go do your
billionaire thing now meaning you go do
your like i'm actually on a rocket ship
i don't have time to socialize anymore
um which you know respect to him dude i
was gonna show you something that i
thought was like a major good find and
now
it seems like achievable given that you
just set the baseline at to 26 year olds
who are now worth 10 billion dollars
this one's a little this one's much
smaller but still oddly interesting uh
go to the the mfm or the uh million
dollar brainstorm document okay that we
have
and scroll down and so you can kind of
see that like this is truthful the guy
sent me a picture of his quickbooks
so you see that yeah i'm looking at it
all right so this guy named matt paulson
so you remember when my twitter got
hacked
yes
so uh there was basically people hacked
my twitter and they tweeted out like i'm
giving away a ps5 or whatever the number
is and just like send me 400 and i'm
donating the money to saint jude's and
this guy matt i when i got back in my
twitter i saw that he sent
two times the asked amount he was like
he's like i just want to set it went
ahead and sent you a thousand dollars
just you know so saint jude has a little
extra money and i i was like oh my god
dude that that sucks i'm so sorry about
this and he was like oh no big deal and
i was like all right well who who are
you that you're this nice and i clicked
out and he runs this website called
market beat have you heard of market
beat only when you uh you you shared
this in the trends group so i did a
little bit of stalking at that time
because i was like what is that you know
your tweet was intriguing you because
you had said something like
i met a guy who runs a company
that does 25 million a year in revenue
only 13 employees
and it was like 17 million of the 25 was
profit and i was like yes
all right
i'm fully aroused tell me more what is
this company you know
got him uh yeah uh and so he sent me a
picture of his quickbooks and he was
like here's the profit and keep in mind
this doesn't include my huge salary my
huge salary is part of the expenses but
we actually do 17 million in profit the
p l that he sent me it's like i think 13
million in profit so it's called market
beat marketbeat.com and uh for the first
two years it was just him and you go to
the marketplace what it is yeah like
what is it yeah you you go to
marketbeat.com like i always google like
hubspot price targets because i'm
curious what hubspot what analysts think
the the stock might be in one year and
he shows up early in google one two
three if you google amazon price targets
target price targets whatever like any
company
and it's he calls it a web portal but if
you didn't know better you would look at
and just call it a media company so you
you see different headlines and
different news it's kind of like wall
street journal but really even more
niche and just for stocks just for
dividend stocks and it's just a way to
really quickly see headlines of what's
coming up so it's kind of like a
a portal or a data aggregator where you
could just like see like all right
this stock has an earnings call on this
date so it's basically just a place to
get information but it's also part
media company because they have they
published 250 articles a year or sorry a
month and they have contractors who they
pay 150 per article to write these but
he told me he goes regardless if the
articles don't actually add to any of
our revenue people come to the website
mostly just to see
like the stock prices and things like
that and so right now the guy has 11
employees and i actually have a list of
sorry 13 employees i have a list of what
they all do
he's got four developers four support
people one ad guy one accountant one
content manager one marketing assistant
and him and uh
they make money through subscription and
through advertising most of which comes
through advertising they've got 15 000
subscribers who pay between 20 and 40
20 and 40 a month
and uh one ad guy selling all these ads
and it's mostly direct marketing and
he's got a bunch of different brands
like he's got um sorry we're going
faster so the just to break down that
revenue
it sounded like subscriptions is
something like four or five million
dollars a year out of the 25 is that
right
uh well he told me 15 000 premium
subscribers and they pay either 20 or 40
a month depending on whichever one they
get so let's call it 30. so that's five
and five and a half million
uh from the subscription from the
premium and then the rest being ad
revenue 20 million of ads okay wow
crazy right and there's only one ad
sales person he doesn't have a team of
ad sales guys and he'll they'll sell
directly to large like uh maybe like the
motley fool or some other like uh stock
picking newsletter or some other
financial brand or some company looking
to promote their stock or different
financial brokers uh financial products
like wealth advisors things like that
but
if an advertiser is too small they just
work with an agency and they just say
hey agency you know we've got some
leftover inventory you want to put your
ads in here and it's just one guy doing
the whole thing
doing all the yeah unbelievable so it
seems like the the trick for them and by
trick i mean hard work and strategy yes
by the way they've been around
i think they've been around for 15 years
right and it was seo it's seo that
drives the bulk of the traffic is that
the idea
i think early on now it has a little bit
of a brand before i even knew the guy i
would actually go to it all the time
just to look because they're they're
interviewing nicely organized like i'm
on like the amazon one right now
and it's basically like it has just like
a bunch of stuff put together it's like
oh here's the execs here's the ceo
here's their age here's their pay it's
like here's the um you know here's the
percent shareholding you know amongst
these different groups yeah it's like
analyst targets etc it's kind of ugly by
traditional web you know 2.0 standards
like it doesn't meet any of the design
requirements that like airbnb would
approve of but in my mind it's perfect
it actually is designed beautifully like
it works wonderfully and so it's like a
cluttered website it kind of looks like
drudge report or craigslist or something
or ebay like it's this messy website but
i think it's quite good we need to put
together a compilation of what i'm
calling sam's ugly ducklings and this is
an example of sam's ugly ducklings which
is his website that like
who the [__] even heard of this it
doesn't look super fancy it's kind of
been around for a while it's got this
like niche passionate audience drug
report is one this is another you've
showed me like 10 of these in the last
year and i think people are i think
people really dig these and so we should
do an episode
that just highlights each one of these
and it doesn't have to be like a podcast
it's almost like a screen share uh maybe
it's just for youtube or like there's
this guy reaching out he's trying to
turn our podcast into like an e-book or
whatever like a really nicely designed
pdf
um we should have him do it on your ugly
ducklings because he's got extensive
notes on what you talk about in each
episode i really do uh this guy in india
i forgot his name but i'm talking to him
right now
to get one of these made for us because
i think it'd be dope right like that'd
be sick dude it's embarrassing like i i
get some people who are like
now there's people who are like i would
say
kind of like a little more successful in
the tech industry that are getting into
our podcast whereas i feel like before
we were kind of like
a different audience for whatever reason
like like kids almost like kids it was
not not kids it was more like just like
entrepreneurial i would say is
definitely a big component of it uh
which might be chaos but might be like
somebody in their 30s that wants to make
a change or whatever or it's just like
yeah i own this awesome business i'm
based out of you know peoria illinois
and it's like what the [__] who are you
and how did you find us
but like that was more of our main
target and now i'm getting people that
are like kind of the heart of silicon
valley that are like dude i kind of got
hooked to the podcast and i'm like dude
i've been telling you about this for
like two years and they're like yeah
it's actually good and they're like
what are like the best episodes you got
like 200 and i was like uh i don't
really know he's like well what's like a
place to find the most popular ones was
like i don't have it he's like is there
a place with summaries i was like nah
not really he's like well you have all
these ideas is there a compilation of
all the ideas it's like ah there should
be someone i think
it's like all the obvious like kind of
like growth things that you would do or
like onboarding things you would do
we've done none of and so i'm like kind
of embarrassed about that but
i'm not embarrassed who cares it's
working
yeah i just think you'd help us like i
think i think i would want that if i was
getting into a podcast
let me this is funny let me tell you how
i found out about market beat i was
reading starter story i like that
website starter story and one of the
questions is what books and podcasts do
you read and he said on the podcast
front i really enjoyed listening to my
first million which breaks down unique
ways that business owners are using uh
unique ways business owners are
generating massive profits that's how i
found out about about this guy is
because he said he listens to us as his
only podcast oh nice
uh that's great
who told you that they're listening
uh i don't wanna say their name but uh
you know someone cool
that's cool that's always funny when
people listen dude i was with my dad
when i took i took my parents to europe
and i brought my parents to this
conference and my parents are like you
know in their 60s from missouri and they
were walking around this conference and
they were like oh we love schwag they
call it schwag i think it's like
i think it's supposed to be swag they go
we love schwag which means free stuff
and they're like oh let's go to this
company get this and it's like some like
european sales marketing company i'm
like you know dad like no one gives a
[__] about like you know sales dot io
like i don't know what they do
yeah yeah and he was like he's like oh
let's go talk to him like dude i don't
like you don't even know what that means
i can tell you what i think what do they
do i'm like i can use words to explain
it but you won't understand and so let's
go get some swag they're giving away
like free
bounty ball bouncy balls like shawarma
but yeah
and he's like
he's like let's go get a ball we're
gonna bring it back for for the kids
with their grandkids they go let's go oh
like oh they have envelope openers like
let's go get one for the kids oh they
got candy i'm like mom this is a
snickers like you could this is awesome
dude he's just gonna give it to you in
the hotel he's like hey kid i got you
this bouncy ball and you're gonna be
like sweet
well they're freaking like they're
bringing like kinder chocolate you know
like kinder like eggs i'm like you guys
realize that you can get that at
7-eleven down the street from your house
like this isn't special and they're just
grabbing all this stuff and they brought
an empty suitcase because they knew they
were going to find schwag and just to
file it so like i come home
i come home and my four-year-old nephew
is like wearing a t-shirt that says like
hi we're here to help with customer
solutions like it just
and it's like and the kids are bragging
that they got that from europe i'm like
oh my god anyway yeah it's european it's
european fashion
yeah
they're like what's this brand gideon
it's just yeah they're just like crazy
and then they're at this conference and
they're like
they're talking to people and they go to
people i hear like i would it was hard
for me to stand next to him and i hear
him talking to people they go hey
do you like podcasts
dude do you love podcasts uh and the guy
was like yeah you know i listen he goes
my dad calls him he goes sam he says he
listens to eight podcasts i'll tell him
to listen to yours what's the name of it
again
and i'm like oh dad like how do you you
know know that you don't know the name
it's called it's called my first one he
goes oh okay i'll tell him hey so it's
called my first million and it'll come
back goes hey i got you another listener
i made a click subscribe
and he's just going up to people saying
like you like podcasts
oh great i got you i'll get you i'm
going to have you subscribe and he
doesn't know the name of the podcast
every single time he goes what's it
called a million dollar podcast
uh he's like i listen to it all the time
it's my favorite but what's it called
again
my mom does the same thing dude she
clicks every ad in my newsletter she's
like i clicked your ads today to help
you i'm like mom i don't know
it's not gonna count it's not gonna do
anything she's like no no you said you
get paid if they click right
like well kind of you know you gotta go
buy the thing
and then she's like oh i'm not gonna buy
it i'm like yeah you also don't need to
click it in fact you don't even need to
read it i don't think you're very
interested in this subject
that's hilarious that is so funny uh god
it's so funny you should have seen them
walking around just like putting around
this conference like saying like oh
sammy come look at let's look at this
booth and it's just i don't even know
what it is like i don't even know what
it is you know what i mean it's like
procurement i'm like i don't i don't
even know what that means dad neither do
you you definitely don't know what that
means
dude that's so funny you said
procurement so so romaine who runs like
he's my basically my partner in my fund
and romaine's got this company that's
like a kind of like an old-school
footballer company in uh based out of
like
georgia right yeah so he lives in
georgia
um so he's like in the tech scene but he
kind of lives in georgia and runs kind
of like a bit of an old school more more
service-based company that like i think
his wife's dad or something started he
like took it over and like grew it a
bunch and it's doing great with it so i
think the business does like 50 million
a year or something like it's like a
sizeable business and so i've asked him
i think no less than 15 times
like so yo yo so what does your business
do again it'd be like yeah we do
procurement for uh for smbs and for
whatever enterprise companies
i'm like
like you get office supplies
like wrap my head around what
procurement is and he's like
he's like you know what the word
procurement means right and i'm like
yeah he's like so it's that and i'm like
but this see i guess i don't know what
the word means then because i still
don't know like like
does anybody use staples anymore like i
don't yeah and it's like oh he's like
he's like it's not office supplies it's
like you know you need a vendor for
something but i was like so then why
wouldn't you just google and get the
vendor he's like yeah but like bigger
companies they just do it differently
they need like this middleman who's
going to basically like help them get
the things that they need
and i'm like
[Laughter]
is it like someone who just like
knows all the people who do blank and
they just
yeah it's like you need vendors i think
i still [__] don't know dude i'm on
explanation number 17. in fact i just
feel bad now every time i i ask him or i
try to tell somebody else
what he does because i'm like i clearly
don't know it's almost like
you know like there's like a spot in my
brain where there's just like if you did
a scan it would just be like oh there's
some dark cloud here it's like yeah
that's the part of my brain that's
trying to understand procurement and
it's just never happening it's just like
a fuzzy region so i've got a story
related to this so uh two days ago
saturday night i went out to dinner at
like the fan a fancy place in st louis
and we get to dinner and my dad goes
all right uh yeah my dad goes hey the
the president of nascar i guess nascar
like performed or raced whatever you
call yesterday sunday in st louis and he
was my dad likes nascar he goes that's
the president
of nascar like jim nance or i don't
forget his name and uh the football
commentator yeah the football i think
it was something that gymnast yeah that
should be and uh he uh and i was like oh
yeah you know he's sitting with this guy
named david stewart he's like the second
richest black man in the world and that
like and it's like it's pretty funny
like i knew exactly who that rich guy
was because he's worth like four or five
billion dollars and i started
researching him and i was like yeah i've
seen that guy before i've seen him on
articles because he's like the second or
third richest black man and he's from st
louis he's like the richest guy in st
louis and he's got this company called
the worldwide systems you've never heard
of that have you no
so it does uh 14 billion dollars a year
uh and it's like the fourth or eighth
like in the top 10 largest privately
held companies in the world and him and
his partner just own own the whole thing
outright and what they do is they're a
systems integrator and that's one of
those words like procurement i heard
that and i'm like
what does that mean and so i went on
this deep dive i'm like i gotta figure
out exactly what they do i i don't
understand this and then like it it says
they're a cisco systems integrator and i
went to cisco's website and i'm like
what a cisco yeah i'm like they're like
networking hardware networking or like
networking hardware and i've like read
those words and i'm like no like the
website would just be like networking
redefined and you're like i didn't i
didn't know the first definition now it
was right
yeah i didn't know how to change that
definition and then like they talk about
like switches and stuff and i'm like i
don't know what like a switch is i guess
has to do electronics like i just i
didn't have i have any idea what this
stuff did uh and but i google it and
like i know that cisco's like one of the
largest companies in the world but i'm
just i like i don't know what it is and
so i had a research it took me forever
to figure out what a systems integrator
is do you know what it is
dude no i don't know any i don't know
what's this i don't know what sap does
i've been on a mission also to
understand i don't know what that is for
a long ass time and they're they're
european though they got a different
word for everything we'd never be able
to figure that i feel like sometimes i'm
watching tv and it'll just pop up sap
and i think it means like closed
captioning or spanish or something like
that i'm like oh hey this is different
now
i'm super confused about sap yeah but i
don't even know why they named their
company after their stock ticker either
it's kind of weird but um
they uh so so a systems integrator
basically so what my father-in-law does
for a living is if you're like chase and
you have a hundred employees working on
floor 18 and you're like hey we got to
move these hundred employees up to 43 in
the same building he studies it for a
few weeks and then you go to home for
work on friday and you come back on the
floor at 47 and you sit down at your
desk that's already set up and
everything just works and there's no
down time and i think system integrators
kind of do that but like if you're a 20
billion dollar company and you're
selling like a three billion dollar
division to this other thing like they
have to go to work one day and like all
their computers are new and like this
new setup exists or if you're like a
hospital and you're like we need an app
it's like well it's not as simple as
just like checking into your lobby and
saying you're there like you got to like
integrate all this crap into it and i
think that's what they do but i don't
know why they don't just call it like an
agency you know what i mean
so
yeah i don't know either but i do know
like you know i guess like jokes aside
you know there's basically things that
are like uh like you know netsuite
network's another one of these where
you're like don't know what what is
netsuite is that like quickbooks but
different it's basically like um
i i mean i'll butcher the thing but like
i mean people use it for like inventory
management for example so it's basically
like a database that's like usable for
um
like it's usable in a couple different
ways it tells you what you got it tells
you what's like running out it tells you
um what you need it'll tell you kind of
like it'll help generate a purchase
order it'll do things like that
by the way if you go to netsuite's
website i just went to it it says
complete procure to pay purchasing oh no
procurement it has to do with this too
but basically there's there's entire
companies i think this is what uh you
know like the key word what deloitte and
other other consulting companies do a
lot of which is basically they teach
your company like these cup these
businesses they're these programs are so
uh unintuitive that there's entire
consulting businesses that generate
billions of dollars a year that just to
go to a company like oh um like right
here on their website lovesack uses them
so it's like you go to lovesack you're
like great you guys sell giant bean bags
huh yeah like you know those things are
getting a little out of hand to get a
little willy-nilly now that it's growing
so much yeah it is sure is
don't you wish there was just a way to
have everything organized in one place
and a system that just all talked to
each other and every one of your
employees can log in and interface with
it they're like that sounds pretty good
so i just go set it up on my own i just
go to the website and they're like no no
we do that for you it takes 12 months
and we will we will add netsuite to your
thing we will add oracle we'll add these
different services to your we will we
will integrate them into your current
business and we'll train your employees
on how to actually use it is that what
service revenue in a sas line so if you
go to like atlassian and look at their
annual report there's a huge amount of
services revenue so do they charge i
don't know what the service how they
what they bucket in services i would
have thought like does that mean just
the software but i i think it's
different for different companies but at
the same time this is sort of like if
you were like hey sean you know uh what
does it mean to blanch a vegetable i'd
be like you know i think it uses hot and
cold water in some way it's like you
know i just don't know right like when
you're asking me about like what are
these like giant enterprise companies
that are like
b2b
service slash software companies like
these are like again i don't know the
first thing about the first thing about
it dude the craziest thing to me is when
i think about these is to understand how
someone came up with this idea so for
example
uh there's octa do you know octa that's
what we use for like logging into like
websites and [__] like that or there's
um what's that one snowflake you know
snowflake yeah like a data so like those
are all companies that are founded
relatively recently like in the
2005-2015 era
and i'm like how did a person
know that this was a problem and had to
get built you know what i mean well
you're just working in a big company
right like okay so for example um
we were talking the other day about uh
what was it called the um
or like like we have yeah like you you
really chimp for companies yeah exactly
uh what was the name of it again i can't
remember the name of my head i just
committed to invest into it but um but
basically
when we were in a company or like you
ran a
you know like an email-based company and
so if i asked you you know like
what does convertkit do you're like very
well versed on like what convertkit does
because you're like well like here's the
scenario you get a bunch of people come
to your website but you you know you
want to grab their email because you're
gonna be able to market to them later so
you so convertkit lets you put up a
little web page that grabs your email
and then once you have it you want to be
able to like tag them or segment them
based on like if they paid for your
thing or if they're free and then like
wouldn't be cool instead of like waking
up every day and like writing the same
email over and over again you could like
automate a sequence of emails one that
goes out on day one one goes out on day
three one goes out on day ten and it's
like you saw a problem in your business
and therefore you know you kind of
understand what the solutions are and
you can even create them well there's
another one that's like
uh like you know that this is basically
what happens when you're when you work
inside of a large company you're like oh
man there needs to be a solution for x
you just see a problem and you're like
there needs to be a solution for x you
understand that context because it's
like
like we spent basically 15 years just
starting companies from scratch you
started media companies i started more
like software social networking type
companies um and we've done content a
bunch so we can tell you all about
content like we just don't have that
that same frame of reference to that
like somebody who's been like you know
somebody who's used this sales force
every single day for like 10 years then
they understand why you need this like
salesforce add-on which app
all the time i'm like damn i wish i knew
how to do this stuff that people charge
a million dollars a year in subscription
revenue i'm like damn i just got to talk
to some stupid freaking guy about
starting a newsletter give the same
spiel constantly i don't want to talk
about how to get your first thousand
subscribers on sub stack you know i'd
rather get paid like a million dollars a
year to do x y and z and you know get a
hundred thousand customers
yeah i mean yeah exactly this is why
like when i was at twitch when we got
acquired i had like i had wrote down i'm
going to walk out of here with like 10
ideas and i i use that import export
framework which is like what are five
ideas that twitch would import a
solution for like we need something like
a country needs something they import it
you know like the us needs oil we import
it from whatever iraq or whatever
afghanistan wherever it needs to come
from uh saudi arabia and so
uh in the same way companies have these
pain points and you're like when you're
sitting there you're like oh damn if
somebody had us if somebody had a magic
way to do this we would pay a hundred
thousand dollars a month for this you
know we would pay x dollars for this
like for example when i was there
i i talked about this idea way back in
the day but like all hands it's like
at our company you know if i needed to
say something to the whole company as a
startup i would just like literally
[__] stand up at my desk and be like
hey hey yo headphones um
we're doing this now the company we've
pivoted to this okay
good uh or like you know we'd be at
lunch and i'd just like stand up and say
something um but like at a company like
twitch 2000 people you know there was
like this organized every thursday
there's an all hands it happens at lunch
they do it at lunch because that's where
they've like a captive audience of
people that will actually sit there and
pay attention because they're eating and
like and they would do the thing and it
had like a presentation and there was
like a whole there was like a conductor
of the whole ceremony and then there's
like a q a and they needed like this
question-and-answer thing then they
needed to stream it to remote employees
it was like all these things they had to
think about and we were just stitching
together like these four different tools
like we use this for the q a we use this
for streaming we use this for the
presentation we use this for new
employees whatever
and i was like oh if somebody just made
like a really good
like uh all hands software i'm pretty
sure you could get a company like twitch
to pay like 25 to 50 000 a year
uh for your software and it would need
to be secure it would need to be you
know easy to stream on your phone they
would need to have the q a integrated
like et cetera et cetera and um
i believe that to be true and like i
could go validate them i could have just
gone and talked to like you know the
head of the all in the all hands thing
and be like hey if this existed would
you buy this
and like
i saw that problem because i was there
before that i didn't even see that
problem
yeah and we had talked about it it was
like a high school newspaper but for
your company yeah by the way workshop is
the name of it it came to me now so
what's the url use workshop.com so it's
pretty sick we talked about this before
which is in insight like we all have
like mailchimp or you have like
sendgrid you have a ton of different
services to send mass e marketing emails
to customers but like there's actually
internal marketing too that happens all
the time like a company is like a small
like you know
tribe and like you constantly need like
information and sort of propaganda from
the top that needs to get to your
employees and whether it's like hey
remember this friday we're doing casual
friday like you know whatever
don't wear underwear this friday but you
have to get some message across about
like what's going on or it's like hey uh
we had these wins in the company like
congrats to this team for launching the
safety feature that saved us whatever um
and so what use workshop does is
basically creates like a little
mailchimp for inside your company so it
lets you do lists did they launch but
did they launch this because of our
podcast or they already know i think
they were already working on it and we
just got connected from
we got connected when they were um
they were doing somebody pointed out to
me they're like hey these guys are doing
almost exactly what you're talking about
i reached out and they're like and the
guy was awesome he's like yeah we had
this past company that was successful we
kind of like
you know like this is our second
merry-go-round got the team back
together to do this
and then it's like it's working hey we
just signed this client this client this
like big name big name big name they
showed me the chart of revenue and i was
like oh this is like
so spot on like i i really think that
that a tool like this is going to exist
and it's going to work
yeah this is sick and like the design is
just really good like if you go to the
design of the page it's like
just like clearly these people are good
at like they're good at simple products
and that's kind of all you need to do to
be able to build something like this is
like nice clean simple easy to use
and they have the use cases so for
employee engagement right a change of
management company alignment hybrid work
mergers and acquisitions internal
marketing it's pretty sick
measuring performance yeah this is
awesome and like you know you send these
emails out normally in your company you
don't have the open rate you don't have
the open tracking you don't know who's
actually engaged who's not in your
company emails you don't know how you
can't test the subject line difference
and be like oh this one got way more
people to respond to the engagement
survey or whatever we sent out and so it
lets the internal comms team like do
their job better they didn't really have
a tool before this
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
are you angel investing actively right
now
yeah
you you stopped right or you like took a
break well i've taken a break because a
the markets and b
because um
i'm working on this i got my i could
talk about a little bit but i got like
20 customers for already for my new
project oh nice okay let's talk about a
second let's do the angel investing
thing first though so
i heard something interesting like my
initial reaction was to do what you're
doing which was like uh it's just
i don't know the world's crazy i lost a
bunch of money
everywhere i look prices are going down
like you know stocks are going down
crypto's going down everything's going
down
um
maybe i should just bunker down for the
season and just like you know chill out
a little bit with investing in these
like high-risk illiquid startups but at
the same time um then i heard somebody
say something i think it was um somebody
on all in on the podcast that one of
their guests he had said something he
was like he's like actually they're like
are you slowing down and he was like no
this is the time to speed up he goes you
know the last few years i was like
getting pretty worried and i thought
like maybe it's time to slow down
because valuations were getting really
high
there's just everybody was there's too
much capital flowing around everybody's
throwing money at everything it's really
you know when you would do a deal it'd
be like you wouldn't be able to get all
the information you need it's like hey
dude we're closing like you're either in
or you're out you don't have time to do
like certain level of diligence
he's like i actually think that those
like uh vintages of companies right like
you know like a vintage of wine like the
1985 bordeaux was so good it's like
basically that happens in startup
investing too where like certain
vintages turn out really good certain
are kind of dry they don't have any big
winners if you look basically after
every kind of like market crash or
recession is like those next three years
are some of the best vintages for
startups and so like this happened after
the kind of 2000 2001 crash and like the
next vintage that came out was like had
linkedin had facebook had like a bunch
of large companies i agree with that but
like the valuations maybe it could have
it's like feels like it's changing week
by week but like two weeks ago when i
was looking at a few deals the
valuations were still quite high
yeah i i think they are coming down and
they're coming down week by week you're
absolutely right and i you know you
could be disciplined on that where
you're just like oh you haven't gotten
the memo that like you know what used to
be 50 million is now 22 million and what
used to be 20 million is now eight like
you you need to get that memo and some
people just haven't got that memo yet
but like a lot right that i'm i'm
waiting like that amount like just a few
more weeks maybe until
so that that's when i say wait that's
what i mean because we were talking to
people and they weren't budging and i
was like well all right well wait and
now i'm getting emails from some like
portfolio companies and they're like you
could see their cash balance and how
much money they have left and it's like
damn man i think there actually might be
like a lot of things going on in
business in six months i i think there
absolutely will be i mean i'm getting a
ton of hey we just raised this extra
money like a lot of smart founders
basically are like taking the bag while
it's available uh just to give
themselves buffer because like who knows
how much worse it's gonna get and um but
the values start coming down so i
actually think that like this this year
next year the next basically two or two
and a half years are going to be like
kind of an awesome
vintage of startups to be investing in
because you're getting all the you know
like none of the big trends have changed
like the world's just getting more tech
enabled tech is just going into more and
more industries size of the price is
getting bigger there's more and more
people coming online machine learning
all that stuff's making stuff better
like all that's still true it's just
that the prices got cut in half so it's
like oh good i'm i'm on board i'm just
like wait i just think that like there's
there's so far been like this two three
week period where it's like there's a
discrepancy
i'll get fixed i think in like two three
four five six weeks yeah you know i
think that's gonna happen pretty pretty
soon should we talk about your uh your
thing
now or you want to do a devoted uh all
right well we could we could yeah i
don't want to do a devoted thing because
i'm not going to announce what it is
entirely yet
so but we can kind of talk about it but
basically uh like i'm kind of going back
to my roots i'm
launching this new thing i'm not even
saying i'm launching it i'm more so like
launching uh enough of it to prove or
disapprove if it's a good idea okay and
i've gotten
[Music]
like
i forget exactly like tens of thousands
in revenue in the first two weeks
amazing and um and i didn't tweet about
it once
so so tell me this tell me uh what
are you doing differently this time
around that you did so the last time you
started this rodeo was maybe six years
ago something like that yeah yeah and so
now with you did the whole hustle
chapter do you get acquired you go to
hubspot you see a bunch of things you
meet a bunch of people you get smarter
wiser all that stuff you got some hair
on your chest now and so it's like
what's
what did you decide like all right this
time i'm doing these things differently
or was it early on early on i was like
against outsourcing or hiring anyone
overseas or hiring like cheap labor or
hourly labor and i was like no i want to
create jobs and i want to like do salary
position with benefits
and now i'm not doing that eventually
maybe we'll add some people like that
but now it's like just how do i automate
this and how do i like get someone
overseas just to do this like a machine
and i just don't really care if i don't
have any employees and i want to you
know i'd prefer being alone so that's
the big difference the second difference
is well this the same similarities i'm
doing it all by hand and this is totally
the right move and i stand by that so
before i wrote everything i sold the
first ads i did it all this time i'm
doing the same thing so i'm literally
doing the cold emailing i'm getting them
on the phone i'm doing the sales i'm
listening to them i'm doing that
constantly and getting those reps in is
actually really impactful and you can
actually like see what's happening but i
by the way i got that revenue
uh zero percent of the revenue has come
through our website it's all been from
cold emailing people on linkedin and
getting them on the phone and then just
sending them a stripe account
amazing
what um
what else what else is different about
your mindset i bet there's more
way more confident for sure um there is
still a sense of urgency uh so like
wanting to move fast and like i have to
get this done i have to do this but more
so like um
i have to get this done but also
remember like i may do this for like 20
years right so like having this longer
term this longer horizon what i learned
with my business we sold around year
five and the truth is
most the value created between year five
and year six was more probably than the
value of zero to five combined right and
i was i wasn't impatient because i'm
happy i did what i did because it
unlocked a lot for my life
but had i not i said this a bunch of
times if i was already wealthy i would
never have sold because
real value seems like it comes like now
i've only experienced a business from
like around year five but it seems like
maybe there's something that happens
you're five years six where values
created and then who knows maybe someone
who's owned a company for years is like
man 20 and 30 is when like [__] magic
really happened so i don't know but i do
think like year five if you bootstrap is
around the time where you're like all
right i recruited some actually good
people i've got people doing helping and
everything but like i don't know do you
agree with like year five year six year
seven is where some crazy stuff happens
i think it's just i think it's just
generally true right like you you plant
seeds and they you water them and you
water them and you're looking at them
you're trying not to just go dig up the
dirt be like why the [__] aren't you
growing but like at some point those
things do start to grow like we're
seeing this with our e-commerce business
too which was
um
uh my buddy had told me this he goes he
goes there's this magic moment in
e-commerce where you've you've brute
forced enough of the like building your
brand and getting cut getting new people
to try you
where every month your returning
customers just come back because they
love your product and you don't have to
remarket you don't have to spend money
remarketing right and then the business
goes from like this giant cash suck to
this giant cash cow if you do it right
and um and i was and we just started to
hit a tipping point like that where you
could say and it's not every month but
there's some months where i'm like whoa
what just happened and it's like
oh yeah that's that's what's happening
like we actually just last year we brute
forced and got a bunch of people to love
our product
and then they came back and bought and
this like a bunch of them came back and
bought this month to where it outweighed
all of the new investments that we're
making like wow that's nice or like at
twitch we were always doing these like
planning exercises about like
you know
these profitability targets um i can't
say too much but like basically
profitability targets
and i think emmett had said something he
was like yeah we from the like he's like
pretty early on we modeled it out and it
was like it's gonna take like 10 years
probably and
this and he said a huge number he's like
x billion in revenue for us to you know
break even and i was like that's just a
crazy idea that it's like we need to get
to x billion in revenue for this to be
profitable
um
and like th but it did like that's
exactly you know that's the that's what
actually how it was playing out yeah and
it's like whoa like i hadn't even really
like amazon i think had a sort of had a
semi similar story amazon i think for 15
years or something like that was like
unprofitable on on the whole but the
difference in amazon was like the
individual divisions were getting very
profitable after like a repeat of like a
reliable like i don't know what's called
four-year cycles like books got super
profitable but by the time books was
getting profitable they were investing
heavily in cds and music and these other
things and so then the total always
looked unprofitable but they knew
internally this is just a clock that
goes you know every x it's going to take
four years or whatever it is to this
unit to get profitable and once they're
all profitable this thing's going to be
like unbelievable which is where it's at
now trusting that process is really hard
particularly for first-time
entrepreneurs with bezos and emmett or i
guess you know after like 10 years it's
like well i'm not exactly a first-time
founder anymore but you know what i mean
well i'll say
the way i'm saying the twitch one right
now sounds a bit like a master plan like
ah i'm i could see this coming and i'll
uh whatever it's like no it was more
like
uh oh [__] we got users oh [__] the
costs are really high what if we raise
money okay what do we got to tell these
guys what are you gonna tell these
investors or how they're gonna get their
money back uh maybe this business model
will work and maybe on this timeline and
then like we update that information
every two years and like
i think you know i think twitch had like
a thing where it's like we're gonna be
profitable in three years and they've
been saying that for the last six you
know like that's just like been a thing
and that's very common actually for
businesses right like yeah like
entrepreneurs generally pretty
optimistic elon's been saying
self-driving cars will come out this
year for four years like you know it's
like entrepreneurs are usually right
about the the actual assessment and
they're wrong about the timeline or
somebody somebody gave me this great
phrase they go
uh don't confuse a clear view for a
short distance it's like imagine you're
driving you see something so clearly but
it's like it looks like it's just right
there right just right around the corner
and like actually that corner is like a
10-year odyssey that felt like oh it's
gotta be just two or three years away
the last big thing that's different
between now and then you know having
some experience versus no experience is
the ability to say no and be like oh
well you're saying you don't want this
product therefore i guess i should
change it it's like oh okay well that's
okay if you don't want it you're
actually not who we're going for i i i
so you you didn't you didn't my takeaway
from this is not you uh that my product
is not good and people don't want it
it's just that i just
i now i know i shouldn't target people
like you and said i should only target
people like this other person right and
that's like the
huge thing where it's like the vision is
that we are going to be this for this
people eventually maybe it can expand
beyond that but for a while this is what
we are and this is who we are for and if
you don't talk to people who you think
you are for then it's okay that's just
they're not the right target market um
and i just targeted that customer poorly
but you should only like you know be one
thing
for one type of person and you go deep
on that and oftentimes people will be
like but that's not that big but a
sometimes it is that big uh and b it's
like that's okay you just gotta like get
that initial traction and then more
opportunity spots itself but you have to
be this one thing for this one person
and ignore everyone else
so my sister has a business i don't know
have i told you about her like cloud
kids thing
well i know she's a
babysitter's a little that's not
actually accurate but like daycare right
it was well so it was
i guess it was kind of like an in-home
daycare that became like a preschool and
became like an outdoor preschool
whatever it kind of evolved yeah by the
way sorry i didn't mean to call that
babysitting
she would punch me in the face and i
knew that wasn't the right i knew it was
a babysitting i was like i called it i
meant to say daycare so yeah that's okay
that's right so
but during covert she pivoted to like an
online thing like a lot of businesses
went from like oh [__] brick and mortar
is really hard right now because they're
like you know every month the government
is changing the rules on what we can if
we can and can't operate our business so
she created this thing called cloud kids
so if you go to cloud
kids with a z
uh
i think it's preschool.com let me see if
that's it
um
yeah
cloudkidswithazpreschool.com so go to
that website real quick and just look at
this um i actually think she's done a
pretty good job with the cloud kids
cloud kids what cloud kit i'll just put
the link here cloud kids with a z
preschool.com so check this out so
um this is like
helping her with this has been pretty
fun because she like she built this in
like wicks i'm like oh which oh it looks
great who's using wix and then and i was
like all right you need to add like
change the headline you need to add like
a video the video needs to be not like a
full-on video like just make it look
like a teacher teaching something like
oh dude this looks amazing exactly so
now it's really good it used to be like
um you know get info now it's like free
trial right like just optimizing the
landing page with her like headline sub
headline button hero image
you know reasons to it reasons to buy
all that stuff like and then she's like
working with people in like fiverr and
upwork to like do these designs it's
like it's actually turned out pretty
good and so she created this thing which
is basically like
um these small group classes so like
let's say you have your kid at home uh
either because they're just like my like
my daughter she's too young to go to
school right now we don't want to send
her to full-time preschool but like we
wanted to like learn something every day
and it kind of takes a [__] ton of
energy to sit there and be like the
engaging patient
parent and like keep your kids attention
and be like i'll teach you like how to
write the letter w today like but like
with this i'm like i sit her down in
front of the computer i get the
materials in front of her with paper and
crayon and like the teacher is like so
good they'll be like all right you know
like hi high five let's sing our welcome
song and then they like do all the
things so for one hour she gets it's
like screen time without the guilt it's
like the
she gets engaged like it's cartoons but
it's not cartoons because she's actually
learning stuff and getting better and so
she created this service and it's like i
was like dude this is actually a pretty
good product
and she um she's hired these teachers
and the teachers like
like in florida and different places
like that so
so then she was she calls me she's like
oh i'm just like struggling so much with
the growth
and so i like i was like all right well
like tell me what like she's like i just
it's not working
what were the numbers and so she gives
her the numbers and she's basically like
i was like okay so let's draw the funnel
and she's like what's a funnel i'm like
all right just imagine like at the top
you know you're getting leads like
people who come to your website and then
some of them give you emails some of
them sign for free trial some of them
actually show up and then some of them
become a fully paid customer so we drew
that funnel out it's like oh actually
this conversion rate is kind of awesome
like why do you and then and i was like
so what's your cost per lead is that
really high it's like no it's like not
high at all and this is with like you
know this like 50 a day 100 a day ad
budget like and she's just like i don't
even know how to do facebook ads i just
put in like you know 100 and i just
wanted to see what would happen
and like i was like wow this is actually
like this business is kind of amazing so
you pay back your customer in less than
a month she's like i don't know if you
say so i'm like yeah like that's what
your numbers say you basically pay back
before your ads bill is even due that's
like the the ultimate like thing you
want with ads driven business is like to
to get the revenue from a customer
profitably before you even pay your
credit card bill and and to give the
listener contact so it prices range from
forty dollars a week
to so you could alright alright i
understand so you can get classes one
day two day three day four day a week
they it all ranges from like 160 a month
to 400 a month
and you get it's basically it's a the
the tagline is actually quite good it uh
although the website needs a little work
like i clicked on the faqs and it goes
to privacy policy but that's all right
live online preschool classes the number
one live preschool program from home we
per this is the beautiful line we
provide the curriculum teachers and
friends right that's a that's great and
then uh there's a video who is this like
this woman who works for her you don't
have a white sister yeah yes one more
time
and uh is great i'm all about this this
is beautiful by the way the art is
actually really good yeah i think it's a
group it's pretty good right and so so
this and so then the reason i bring this
up is is because you were talking about
handling a no handling an objection
and what i learned when i was like
diving in i was like your funnel is not
broken your website is good
your services your retention is amazing
um i was like even your ad like roads
your payback period is also amazing so i
was like what are you talking about this
thing and she's like well i mean like i
talked to like you know so many people
they all just you know they don't come
back
for the from the free trial i'm like but
you're converting 20 or something like
that to from free to paid that's like
yeah best on the internet yeah but like
i talked to eight moms that were like
you know we can't do it for this for
this reason
and i was like yeah but eight out of ten
eight out of ten knows
that means two out of ten yeses that's
20 conversion that's again amazing and
the numbers back out where this business
is like an awesome business
and i think the the site what happened
was the psychology because i told her i
was like hey if you want to close more
people call everybody who just did your
free trial and see if they'll convert to
pay don't be like hey i'm i'm the owner
of the school how did you like it uh so
glad you know i saw i dropped in on the
class i saw she was doing great um like
do you think you want to continue and
like do you want to do more classes um
and like oh payment's a problem like we
can help you with the payment plan
because a lot of the people who are
doing this they're like detroit inner
city like there's a lot of people that
are basically like hey i can't pay for
full-time caretaking i can't pay for
even full school uh or like in detroit
for example what i learned through this
was in detroit the public schools are
full so you just can't send your kid
can you believe that so people are like
six years old and they're like yeah this
school's full and i can't afford private
school it's like i've never heard public
school could be full and like that's
what's going on in detroit right now is
this is this is your sister's just like
move over sean there's a new there's a
dude big like a d at the house well the
funny thing is she's she's got a better
product in business than i have in any
of my businesses in terms of all the
core metrics are stronger than all of
mine the product offering the retention
stronger than anything
the problem is not a problem actually
she doesn't want to like she's not
trying to do world domination she's like
no this would be great if we got to like
50 students and like well then you'll
want 100 right she's like no because
that'll be way more work like
at 50 i already have these great
teachers i can handle 50 i just want to
fill up my occupancy and like she truly
is like well because when i do that and
then i can go work out in the middle of
the day and like i just want my
lifestyle i can go to my daughter's
thing you know sean you know she has
something that you'll never know oh no
the e word
enough yeah i see that she doesn't have
enough my uh i i went through i went
with my mother-in-law she's like hey sam
can i drive you to the airport i was
like why do you as well it's two hours
to get there i need you to explain to me
how online commerce works because i want
to start a store
this was two or three years ago and i
like did the ride and i told how to use
the store now she's got a business doing
like half a million a year and i was
like so why don't you scale this why
don't you do this why don't you do this
you could be like i'm always like you
could be like the black martha stewart
like you could crush this
and she's like
but i like taking tuesdays and thursdays
off and i was like oh right well
but if you made more then you could take
two says a third off she's like i could
do that right now
right so yeah it's the same exact thing
that i'm like but but but
but and just to finish the point on the
the rejection thing what i learned was
when she called people and eight people
in a row said no it was like completely
demoralizing to her and she started to
question everything it's like
am i going after the wrong market do i
have the wrong product am i have my
price too high am i this am i that
and i think it's really important to be
able to back out numbers i've seen the
same mistake on fundraising all the time
so it sounds kind of silly when it's
like oh my sister's a little preschool
oh you know it's just 20 conversion rate
obviously that's good um like even if it
was 10 it would still be great like it
still work um
like oh that's so silly you know she got
demoralized by by hearing you know eight
nos in a row you know on a monday
morning and um or not even hearing no's
just not hearing back from people i'm
like yeah yeah but then i talked to
founders and they're like dude raising
money so hard i need to change this
change that can you help me with my
pitch i'm like how many investors did
you pitch to and they're like yeah we
talked to like you know these four last
week i'm like four
and i'm like you know this is a numbers
game this is a sales funnel and you need
you're selling your equity in your
business in exchange for money and like
like what you're doing is you're getting
highly emotional and you're taking it
highly personal that somebody doesn't
want to fund your business
and like in reality yes you should be
learning from like how to pitch better
and like maybe maybe in the end you will
strike out but you don't even know that
yet you haven't hit enough people dude
what a lot of people realize is that
like one to three percent conversion
rate is like normal which kind of means
that like maybe you'll go over 29 and on
the 30th one you get a one and that's
like boom you know you're now you're one
for three or you're uh you're you're
that's a three percent conversion rate
you're good yeah or maybe on your 99th
one the tenth one boom one percent of
100 that's good that's why i always joke
with ben i'm like
mormons are probably the best sales
people because
convincing someone to join a religion
has like the lowest conversion rate ever
and then you hear that like you could
sell salesforce and that has a two
percent conversion rate and you're like
piece of cake this is this is the
easiest thing ever ever versus
commission
then how many
like i i don't know like if that's
actually what you did where you tried to
get people to like quit whatever
religion they were in and join your crew
but how many people do you think who
were like either atheists or in another
team and they just said yeah cool i'll
i'll join your thing how many people
what what's what was your percentage
rate
uh so let's see i have did you convert
anyone
yeah i converted uh low 30s uh i'd have
to look like 32 people on my mission so
i was two years
and um
oh man how many doors do i think i
knocked on in in that time
uh
i mean it was a couple hundred or a
thousand uh it was hundreds of doors a
day
across to every every single day for two
years right so you knock down a hundred
doors a day easily easily a hundred
doors a day
what country hold on we're doing some
public math this deserves it let's say
well
yeah while you do it let me ask you a
question what kind of so i was in el
paso texas but i was speaking spanish
so if you did 150 doors a day which
you're saying easily uh is estimate
every single day 365 days two years you
knocked on a hundred and nine thousand
doors you you did 109. three thousand
thirty thirty and you did 32 at 109.
uh so that's 0.00
0.02 or 0.002 something like that some
something that's like
yeah fraction
fractions of a percent
dude how about the fact that your
friends were all going these cool places
in africa or south america and they sent
you to el paso yeah but i mean you know
yeah my brother went to prague my sister
went to moscow uh
but uh
we had um what's his name austin from uh
lambda school which is now bloom tech he
went to russia he was in russia or
something like that he said he converted
zero or one he was like oh because we'd
ask what would be good he's like
one would have been great yeah for where
i was
that's the trade-off you make is that
like yeah my brother and sister were in
much cooler places in eastern europe but
like eastern europe was hard man like
really hard but i thought like so i
guess you're dealing with uh mostly
mexicans or some type of hispanic yeah
they're they're the most hardcore
catholics there are they they're they're
willing to well so you gotta realize
though el paso is like uh very
transitory a lot of people just got
there from from mexico and so it's like
ah well i'm not really going to my
church that i used to go to maybe i'm
looking for something new like my life
is already changing i'm open to
something new
you know facebook has a similar feature
it's called recently moved and those are
great people to target
it's true dude recently moved is an
awesome group of people to target
because they're changing their life
yeah yeah exactly if you have like a
weight loss thing um ben can you give me
the like speed version of what is the
pitch so you not you literally
physically knock on a door
i open up what happens
yeah so essentially what we're taught to
do uh is no just like do it
i mean in spanish yeah do it to me do it
to me no blowing you got to do it
you guys gotta you gotta bear with me
it's been uh okay so i'm um thirty-four
it's been 13 years you did this a
hundred thousand times you know this
like yeah abc so uh
know i'd say hi how are you my name is
elder wilson this is i got my companion
with me this is elder
lopez uh
uh how are you today you know just
whatever hi good i'm doing great nice to
meet you uh gosh how gosh i'm sorry hold
on let me think about this what do you
want okay we'll give you a second
cook
it i can get into it but like how would
i first first start that's what i'm
trying to think of how many times did
people tell you to f off
uh i couldn't begin to tell you
i mean more often than do they train you
or you just sort of figure out how to
sell them you go to
uh well so
you have three weeks of training if
you're speaking english if you're
learning a language it depends on how
difficult the language is i got six
weeks of training i think
do you carry mace no
no weapon no nothing like a whistle you
have a whistle no i i think maybe the
the
women
it might be up to their own discretion
maybe they do some stuff like that i
have a friend who got stabbed he was in
honduras uh like a good buddy of mine
got stabbed on his mission um
lethal and weapon here yeah
uh how i i you know
um
start off with just like um
you know we're missionaries from the
church of jesus christ of latter-day
saints and you you start off by asking
them questions like uh do you believe in
god uh are you someone who who believes
in god yeah oh uh you know like
what do you believe about i do go to a
church oh yeah i go to a church and so
you start with kind of relating to them
about their faith and then you say well
you know our message is that uh you know
you said you believe in jesus christ we
also believe in jesus christ from the
church of jesus christ of latter-day
saints and what we believe is that the
same christ the same church that christ
established when he was on the earth
2000 years ago was lost for a period of
time um and and so no one had the
complete truth but that it's been
restored again that exact same church
and so that's why we're out here trying
to to talk to people if you knew that
was true that christ church was was back
on the earth the same one that he
established is that something that would
be interesting to you
no oh my gosh this is awesome just the
sales call the wolf of
dude uh that's fascinating man i feel
like by the way you know
whoever runs the budget at the uh you
know the mormon church me and sam are
available for consultation if you need
some uh some uh you know tips on how to
brush up that that opening script i
think maybe those first few lines maybe
we could give you some other hooks maybe
some other some other other ways in
because also like have you seen the
trends on tic tac where it's like a baby
or something like running away and they
overlay uh audio that says excuse me
ma'am can i talk can i talk to you about
the lord
you know can i talk to you about the
lord ma'am have you been to church
lately ma'am where are you going can we
can we please talk it's like always like
some funny running away uh you guys
should pounce on that man would it be
valid to do your mission through tick
tock like if you were like i'm gonna
make amazing tick tock videos that go
viral and help spread our mission like
could you do that is that like or it has
to be door knocking um well no so during
covid a lot of
um
missions kind of went to social media
essentially um now you got to realize
that like your mission is like a it's a
rite of passage really like for two
years when i was 19 to 21 years old i
didn't have any contact with my family
except for i wrote them an email once a
week and then i got to call home on
christmas and mother's day that was it
so like completely separated from my
past life um like doing this extremely
hard thing and so
during covid uh missionaries
did like start doing like social media
missions because they couldn't go to
people's doors and talk to them but my
impression was like man that sounds like
sucks like you missed out on the rite of
passage like
i wouldn't want to do that for two years
like that doesn't sound fun
just exploring yourself losing your
virginity going to parties converting
people
you're saying
man that sounds like it sucks i wouldn't
want to do that and like when you
describe like not seeing your family and
like you know having to like whatever
you said like you know
like if you're going to wash your knees
every day or whatever like you want it
to be hard you want it to be like this
like life-changing difficult crazy thing
that you do with your life not like
sitting behind a computer for two years
that's the difference between mormons
and gentiles like us yeah exactly
there's a bunch of heathens dude i spent
my whole life avoiding hardship like
well i would be in the military or like
you know the morbid church or whatever
like if i really wanted to lean into
like difficulty i spent my life running
away from difficulty we we are not the
same
oh yeah we are not the same
yeah then it is like a big cultural
thing it's hard to explain how excited i
was for this again i have two years
oh my god well that's why uh you're you
know are going to be probably more
successful than both of us
and happier and um and happier yeah and
more emotionally i have a ton of respect
for anybody who does that i also have
even more respect for whoever
was able to convince people to do this i
think that is like one of the
greatest you know like uh
greatest like organizations that that's
been created like with such a strong
pull
that its members would take such a like
large you know uh movement and and like
to support it like
and they're obligated to convince 10
other people to join yeah i'm trying to
get somebody to give me their email
address for like two seconds and i'm
like they have to give you like they
have to give you 10 of their income they
got to give you 10 of their income and
go and recruit about 50 more people
it's the greatest thing ever two years
your life 10 of your income all of your
social capital and uh probably something
else that i don't even know about and
we can't pay taxes either because we're
giving it all away
it's the it's the sweetest deal in the
world it is it is a great deal 10 is
cheap on what you get in return
wow oh wow amazing and you have to
believe it's the greatest deal in the
world
even better wow amazing
i didn't enjoy this man i've never seen
them
i'm convinced now you're like do you
guys want more so let me i'll tell you
this i do i do i pay 10 of of all of my
income i
donate a ton of time it sucks all my
time i donated two i gave two years i
paid for two years to be on this mission
okay i get i give up a lot but at the
same time like if i move anywhere
i
show up at a new place i call the local
congregation a bunch of dudes come help
me unpack my boxes and move in i go to
church i immediately have like a dozen
friends people invite me over to dinner
for the first few nights that i'm in
this new city um if i
need if i need a job there's someone you
know dedicated in the congregation who
will help me find a job if i'm ever like
down on my luck and i need food
the church of jesus christ life saints
will provide me with food make sure i
don't go hungry like um you just
described being a famous podcaster also
by the way
sam just sam went on a road trip last
year and was just like hey who wants me
to drive their car and people are like
here here's the keys and he's like hey
um
anybody here's wife want to cook me
dinner and give me a massage people are
like honey honey
sam's in town
maybe i maybe i am mormon after all
exactly
uh i mean i i look like it maybe i am
mormon maybe i should do a dna test
jokes aside and also i don't have the
wrath of god if he does exist against me
so you know uh
i think it is pretty awesome and also
like i think people study like what
makes people happy in the end i think
the biggest always religion that's
always part of it well i think the
biggest one is is like uh quality time
spent with people you care about which
like is a combination of like family
friends communities the spiritual
community all that stuff and so what
you're describing is basically like
that's awesome meaningful relationships
with people who like you know have like
kind of an unconditional support of each
other which is great and something that
everybody would sign up for
um you know
depending on you know with the situation
the cost i do think believer believers
in a religion live longer than
non-believers and i also think they're
happier uh i i was curious about that
sean that wasn't are they gonna have a
succinct uh pitch for for why it's a
great thing we need to send you on a
mission
i would love to go knock on uh i would
love to go knock on 100 i really want to
just do door-to-door sales just to see
if i could do it and how it would the
pitch needs to be excuse me man do you
know what the average life expectancy of
an atheist is
now what if i were to tell you that
mormon believers it's this would that
interest you right we i don't know if if
uh if the church would go for this but
if they would we should do a youtube
series where like we send
sean with a couple missionaries i can
hook you up with in the bay area and
just go knock on like 100 or 200 doors
with them and like
see what it's like offer your thoughts
and then like
give them some observations and tips
from uh
well i would like to just go sell my own
fake religion and just see
that like how well i could do um because
you know i need i need that kind of
fresh slate i'm more of an entrepreneur
not an entrepreneur if you know what i
mean
so i i got to create something from
scratch here
and
keep all those tax benefits to myself as
well i've actually considered this many
times about creating my own religion um
because i do have my own philosophy my
own belief system i do share it with
others and uh
and uh it's a life operation and i don't
like taxes and i think that it's
fantastic to to own a religion or to go
to church of a religion and you're
indian so you know you can be a guru
like people expect that you know
i know i mean when i had the longer hair
i was much better suited for this but
you know if i like sam what would be
your opening line like what where what
direction would you take it like he was
like hi i'm ben do you have a moment to
talk about i would have said exactly i
would say excuse me ma'am i know this is
so strange but i gotta ask you a quick
question what would you say if i told
you that the average life expectancy of
an atheist was 72 but the average life
expectancy of a mormon is 84. would you
want to know why
and i think they would say
yeah i guess well you see it's do you
want to see your grandkids someday yeah
like well because when you believe in a
religion it means this this and this and
it just so happens our religion i would
tell them well that's why it was good
that he he started with do you believe
in god
right because he could get the losers
out of the way well don't you got to
separate i say are you talking to an
atheist are you talking to somebody of
another religion because you can't you
got to know which way you're going there
the other way is you know you do the
thing where you're like um
uh you know
hey um you know i was just at your
neighbor's house and i thought i would
pop by um just so you're like i hate
when i'm in the neighborhood uh i would
say
yeah i was at the johnson's across the
street and um
uh you know i thought i'd stop by
because um
blah blah blah or like you know i really
just wanted to chat with you for a
minute do you do you believe in god all
right you know maybe go with something
that's like um
uh i was just wondering have you seen
this video
just hold up my phone of that tick-tock
of the baby uh we chased away like i'm
just trying to like you know stun them
into not not like automatically
rejecting me right like it's like how do
i get some curiosity which would be
something like um
you know i'm going around the
neighborhood i'm just asking you know do
you go to church uh regularly and
they're like oh yeah right
awesome uh would you say you believe in
god
yeah i do believe in god
um you know where did that start was
that from your parents
yeah my mom was super religious my mom
too
and then i was like you know trying to
do something like that that's off the
top of my head how i would try to like
you know build rapport quickly as i get
them to talk you know take the podcast
[Laughter]
hey give me give me a hundred thousand
reps at this i think i'd be pretty good
by the end yeah better than ben and
having to think about it yeah ben's
response made me think he might he might
not have uh gone on that mission after
all hey sean 32 converts you've got zero
so far so you got to get on my level
i just don't know how you forgot the
script you said a thousand a hundred
thousand times that sounds a little
suspicious over a decade's a long time
sean a decade's a long time
all right i gotta go bathroom i'll talk
to you all a little bit
[Music]
you